hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the amnesia custom story
Emma's story by Neal Winkler now this is
another exceptionally highly reviewed
I've got a whole whole huge list of very
very very well reviewed so expect a lot
of amnesia content throughout the next
few months because I've got a stock bio
to play non-stop entertaining I mean
some people understand how amnesia you
know some people I feel it's overplayed
but remember this is all fresh to me I'm
a newcomer today and these are
relatively self I like and I hope you
enjoyed my reactions to it anyway you
are Emma daughter of a steam scientist
got the Robert Coleman ever since his
discovery of the mythical orb of power
is vanished leaving you alone in the
family estate strange things happening
you wonder what has happened to him the
story begins as you wake up in your room
to find an ominous note from your lover
as you play you will unravel in my story
ha ha ha ha ha yeah
I think this one scored a 9.2 overall I
mean some of the voting is subjective
obviously people have different tastes
but I personally like to pick like I'm
never gonna just play it easier to just
play I mean I want to experience things
that people create because there's
nothing I like more than seeing what
people can make it just it's inspiring
to see what people can do for completely
for free that people make these things
not expecting to make money off of it
obviously it's good letter from Neill
dearest Emma I don't know how this note
will ever reach you or find you but I'm
in trouble I'm currently in captivity
placed here I dare to say it by your
father he has always been a bit off but
this time he most certainly has gone
insane I've never seen him like this
before I believe it to be related to
that object the orb of power that he
found while on his latest trip out of
the country is somehow changed him I
know he keeps it in a secret room of his
lab secret room of his in his lab at all
costs you must locate this orb destroy
it only then should your father
returning normal please be careful but
make haste
remember find the lab and destroy that
or or the herb your lever Neil I don't
know about you ladies but if Neil had
the boys
ha nevermind
nope is not a jest I lied to myself
about that okay I don't see you an oil
in ER but then I got a son that dark I
imagine that's gonna change rather soon
anything in the boot shoot anything
give me your secrets okay it's okay
Oh clock is actually ticking that's it
it's subtle you know you know that a
custom story is good when there's subtle
details like that hello big empty
hallway
hello mannequins statues the door is
locked there must be a key around here
somewhere
first sir the door is locked must find a
key for this Menon or what if Emma had
my voice huh what's with these chairs
lined up blank I should explore this
first floor first before leave I should
okay I trust you all right anything by
there whose mass is paid hmm
feel for the lantern which I don't have
I'm assuming that it wants me to explore
this floor to find a lit wow this is a
big place no just storage room is locked
sword room is locked
we'll need a key a note some low donum
and I'll hammer her this is assume that
emma is a rather burly bodybuilder you
know type chick and she has a kind of a
deep voice for fifth of May 1823 this
letters congratulate talk to Robert
Coleman on his invention of laudanum
another inventor whose laudanum laudanum
I don't even know how it's really
pronounced now down it down him that's
how it's pronounced your invention heals
all ailments and feels so good when used
for this we award you this piece of
paper congratulations and go suck a dick
because this is all we're gonna give you
signed Neville Worthington Neville the
douche Worthington forgive them for
something that cures all ailments they
give him a piece of paper hey hey good
job there friend oh I know that took
years there's no work no prize money no
anything okay shirts mysterious shirts
chest
um mysterious chest 20th of April 1822 I
have stashed an extra supply of
tinderboxes and a lantern in the storage
closet adjacent to this room in case of
emergencies if it is locked which should
be use this key to gain entry I could
have figured that out all by myself
according to the note
according to the note according to the
note there is a lantern in some extra
tinderboxes in a storage room next to
this one you think I know that living in
this house that I live in
Hey ah it's a bright sunshiny day Wow
Wow
kind of foggy oh right okay I'm sure
nothing bad will happen two points F
three points ah okay now we go in the
store this is a bust of her father well
he ugly hmm clink clink clink why so
dark Weissenberg
clicking - I said smash um anything else
in here somewhere
self tinderboxes why is it okay I
thought it was pulsing green for a
second I was like wha hell yeah looks
like that's about it I'm assuming wait
wasn't there
hang on let me go check this door over
here know something because it was
another room those loud why is
everything so doc you heard me so doc
god damnit what the hell oh it's not
ready for that
holy crap oh there's no Closet in your
on boat uh hide in the corner ah I was
uh uh not ready I'm just you know what
no no messing around in the first level
okay all right okay I also got a new
wallpaper up I try I finally changed
from the standard Windows wallpaper
which I've had for about two and a half
years now and I went to a creepy one and
on my second monitor here it's kind of
staring at me in the face I did it
because it was a bright blue Windows one
and kind of one lemarcus fear okay 10th
of November 1825 to dr. Coleman hello
robert
I had that key to the metal door that
metal door on the second floor created
today it should arrive within the week
probably longer knowing our Parcel
Service do be careful in that room now
we don't want any more incidents like
what happened to the butler last month
do we ha ha ha he died ha ha I can still
hear that awful scream sometimes in my
nightmares he did die anyway I hope all
is well with you your friend
Braxton OTT Braxton Archer Thaxton oh
okay no no the tf2 references I'm
assuming you did
sup I assume they're here be monsters am
I not supposed to go I can but should I
I still hear birds
hello and now let's go find out what's
in the middle door before I leave this
area one way or another oh lordy this
does not look good
oh wait what could have happened to him
how did he hurt himself come in room why
why did it ever
Oh No hey like I ever hey I gotta go
gonna get hit ever do haha lock is
broken that's magic oh oh no oh no oh no
oh I hate me
I am I hate them all I hate him I hate I
hate I hate anymore
Oh was there anything else in there I
don't know maybe it was something appear
in the closet effort oh no it's still
there guys I'll go I'll go
oh yeah I'll go I'll be on my merry way
and nothing Bad's gonna happen else
somehow I knew that cursed orb would
come back to haunt me
why didn't he even try to warn me
or at least prepare me for this I don't
know why I don't know why I mannequin so
much I don't know why I never knew that
about myself I never knew that I hated
another slightly crooked I think there I
never knew that about myself until I
started playing a music Oh Oh what is
going on here another clock oh okay I'm
okay
I'm okay Oh date missing can't believe
he's dead I'm gonna miss him playing on
the piano at dinnertime it just won't be
the same however I must admit as nice of
a fellow he has he seemed I could not
help but sense some deep anger or hatred
within him against this house although I
pray finds peace in the afterlife
I get the feeling the rest is illegible
stuck shut
take a chair Oh who be playing the pan
er don't be doing that I don't have much
oil do I know any not who's playing the
piano
let uh I'll be there any more doors oh
it's nice and bright here I like nice
and bright gotta keep it tight and
bright tighten right or spams E and E if
anyone down the Hope who span D and E is
just YouTube it it's hilarious
all right so I don't want to go down
here I don't want to go up huh let's
take the most slow meandering path down
the stairs manikins okay so I got the
damn er
for that
duh suspicious foot boards blocked the
wine cellar door gotta find some kind of
braking tool maybe a crowbar maybe a
hammer our nope I could do it if I was
here right come on my characters a big
burly bodybuilding chick come on she
could break through that with her bare
hands
nope nope nope nope nope nope nope no no
no no nope nope nope no no no no
nope no nope Oh looking at a lot of time
alright so thank you all so much for
watching let me know what you think of
this one
I get a feeling there's gonna be a good
one so thank you all so much for
watching and as always we'll see you in
the next part
bye bye